thank you very much in just a few hours
president Trump will leave the White
House and head to Tulsa for that
campaign rally in a new interview the
president is defending his decision to
move ahead with the events this as he
tries to put out some fires closer to
home such as a book by his former
national security adviser and then
abrupt Friday night firing at the
Department of Justice
Nikole Killion is covering all of this
from the White House Nicole good morning
to you
hey good morning to you Jeff President
Trump said in an interview with Axios
that he does not intend to wear a mask
tonight and he doesn't feel like he's in
any danger he said we have to get back
to living our lives and he promised a
wild evening in Tulsa it's been an
interesting period of time in a new
White House video President Trump said
the US economy is rebounding from the
corona virus pandemic our country will
go on and we're gonna be stronger than
ever before the president's message
comes as he proceeds with his first
campaign rally since the Kovach crisis
began even as dr. Anthony Falchi a key
member of the coronavirus task force
signaled concern he spoke to CBS news
radio Steven Portnoy about the
likelihood of the virus spreading at a
mass gathering it's very clear that the
risk exists the event was postponed by a
date due to Juneteenth the White House
called the occasion a celebration of our
nation's unsurpassed ability to triumph
over darkness and it disputed the
president was unaware of the
commemoration
which marks the end of slavery here not
just learning about Juneteenth that this
week that's simply not true
the reverend al sharpton at a Juneteenth
rally in tulsa
so either he's lying or he is clearly
exposing the ignorance that he has about
black history the administration also
continued damage control in court Friday
over a scathing memoir by former
national security adviser John Bolton
it's published by Simon & Schuster a
division of Viacom CBS government
attorneys argued the book should be
blocked because it contains classified
information but a federal judge said the
horse seems to be out of the barn since
copies have already leaked the president
isn't worried about foreign governments
reading this book he's worried about the
American people reading this book the
judge is expected to rule before the
book comes out Tuesday late last night
the Justice Department shook up its own
ranks by the President and nominating J
Clayton the head of the Securities and
Exchange Commission to replace top New
York prosecutor Jeffrey Berman Berman
has handled as several investigations
involving the president and his campaign
he said he found out about all these
changes in a press release from the
Attorney General and said he has not
resigned Michelle I'm sure we'll be
hearing more about that Nicole thank